yesterday we talked about this
disastrous arms deal that Donald Trump
signed with Saudi Arabia over the
weekend which effectively gives Saudi
Arabia 350 billion dollars worth of
weapons over the next 10 years and it
makes the us even more complicit in war
crimes that Saudi Arabia is committing
in Yemen war crimes that they're going
to continue committing using American
weapons that they now will have and it
seems like effectively an endless supply
of thanks to this deal we have now
learned that Donald Trump's son-in-law
and advisor Jared Kushner is said to
have negotiated this deal with Saudi
Arabia what a deal huh really tough one
to negotiate Kushner did call the CEO of
Lockheed Martin and asked her to lower
the price of a missile defense system so
that the Saudis would be able to I don't
know more smoothly agreed to the deal
and now here's the kickback the day
after this deal was signed Saudi Arabia
announced that it would be donating 100
million dollars to a charitable fund
that was started by Jared Kushner's wife
also known as Donald Trump's daughter
Ivanka Trump this is yet another one of
those situations like that Donald Trump
meeting with the Russians in the Oval
Office the day after he fired the person
in charge of the Trump Russia
investigation Michael Flynn you would
think that the Trump administration and
the people that they deal with would
want to maybe put more than one day
between events like this because they
were clearly this clearly presents the
appearance of a conflict of interest but
maybe they just feel that nobody can
touch them and they actually might be
right the stated mission of this fund
started by Ivanka is to help women
starting their own businesses so maybe
Saudi Arabia also likes the idea that
they can appear to be on the side of
supporting women even though women need
permission for almost anything they do
in the country of Saudi Arabia well I
think because this money is going to a
charity it kind of causes people to turn
the other way as if it's not a
corrupting influence and it's similar
and it's in a way to when foreign
dignitaries say at Trump's hotels in
Washington DC yeah maybe they just think
it's pennies on the dollar to this guy
because he's a billionaire it doesn't
add up to any sort of bribery but it
still is well not only there's not only
that angle to it but I mean it's like a
broken record at this point
as always with Trump a hypocritical
double standard is not far behind at a
debate in October Donald Trump commented
about donations made by Saudi Arabia to
nonprofits specifically to a non-profit
known as the Clinton Foundation Donald
Trump said quote Saudi Arabia giving 25
million Qatar all of these countries you
talk about women and women's rights
these are people that push gaze off
business off buildings these are people
that kill women and treat women horribly
and yet you take their money so I'd like
to ask you right now why don't you give
back the money that you've taken from
certain countries that treat certain
groups of people so horribly yet again
Trump debates Trump no comment now about
the donation from Saudi Arabia hypocrisy
from Trump aside this is all just a
coincidence right Pat I mean 350 billion
dollar arms deal Saudi Arabia the next
day gives a hundred million to a charity
started by Ivanka Trump these are mere
coincidences right you can tell they're
doing this to try to make their own
image look better because of course you
know women need male Guardians in Saudi
Arabia to do even basic things like
getting around yeah and it's kind of
like when Walmart has their drives for
their own employees and charity at the
end of all yeah yeah yeah and it's to
make up for the fact that the employees
don't have unions that they often
receive minimum wage so it's an easy
counterpoint for them to make Ivanka
Trump is technically not in charge of
the fund right now if she was this would
actually be illegal the way it is now
it's just yet another one of these
massive conflicts of interest Harvard
Law Professor Lawrence tribe said to the
Washington Post quote at the very least
a donation is a present which if made by
a foreign government or an agent of such
a government or an entity controlled by
it is expressly banned by the text of
the foreign emoluments clause with
respect to anyone holding any office of
profit or trust under the United States
even if Ivanka Trump somehow manages to
create formal distance between herself
and that version of the Clinton
Foundation the hypocrisy of the
move is jaw-dropping such contributions
would surely constitute a financial
benefit to her brand and her family's
brand Trump has this sort of strange and
suspicious relationship with the Saudis
in general we know that the Trump
Organization recently incorporated for
businesses in Saudi Arabia Trump only
stopped his new hotel project there in
December after winning the election he's
been critical of Islam and he's been
pretty antagonistic towards many Muslim
countries with the exception of Saudi
Arabia in the context of the Muslim ban
which included eight countries seven
countries depends which version we're
looking at did not include Saudi Arabia
there and it should have I mean
according to the internal logic of the
Muslim BAM and again I'm not saying I
support the Muslim ban but I'm saying
according to the logic Trump stated for
that ban why wouldn't Saudi Arabia be on
that list Pat and I think the reasons
have a lot to do with the types of
business that the US and even Trump
specifically do with Saudi Arabia I
think this gets back to the
contradictions between Trump now and him
on the campaign trail because he even
advocated for in retrospect going after
Saudi Arabia instead of Iraq because of
course fifteen out of the nineteen 9/11
hijackers were from Saudi Arabia yeah
yeah that's right and I was going to get
to that also which is when you look at
who is actually doing terror around the
world from these countries in a way that
impacts the United States number one on
the list is Saudi Arabia when it comes
to the most major terrorist attack on
American soil to round out the story
I've got a little cringe moment for you
remember at the end of The Daily Show
Jon Stewart used to have a moment of Zen
I'm calling this a moment of cringe this
is Donald Trump dancing with Saudis and
their swords during this trip
[Music]
yeah I don't think there's much more we
can say about that is that better or
worse than his dance moves with Ben
Carson I think it's much worse okay I
think it's much worse